Почему дети или другие люди становятся
неблагодарным Как сделать людей
благодарными вы никогда не сможете
сделать своих детей благодарными если не
будете знать источники и механизмы
благодарности и это кстати относится не
только к детям Это относится и к
родственникам сотрудникам Да и вообще К
любым людям после просмотра этого видео
вы Точно будете знать как сделать людей
благодарными это очень важное видео
поэтому досмотрите его до конца чтобы
чётче и глубже понять почему люди бывают
или становятся неблагодарным Давайте
сначала разберёмся что же такое
благодарность благодарность - это наша
эмоциональная реакция или чувство
выражающиеся В желании отблагодарить за
то что нам сделали или дали Не будучи
обязанными Например если Вы заплатили
кому-то за что-то или кто-то по
должности или статусу обязан был вам
что-то сделать дать или предоставить то
у вас не возникает чувство благодарности
когда он это делает согласитесь другое
дело
сделает вам больше того что он обязан
был сделать или если он дал вам больше
того за что вы ему заплатили то у вас
сразу же возникает чувство благодарности
и желание его отблагодарить Таким
образом мы видим что благодарность - это
чувство которая возникает в ответ на
благо которое нам дали Не будучи
обязанными уже чувствуете причины и
Механизм благодарности благодарность -
это механизм мотивации обеспечивающий
кругооборот эги в мире именно благодаря
этому механизму в мире размножается
добро именно этот механизм побуждает нас
отвечать добром на добро когда мы
говорим о полученном благе имеется в
виду конечно же не только что-то
материальное это может быть и
нематериальное например ваше ощущение
счастья и ваше состояние
благополучия благо - это удовлетворен
потребность а потребность быть
благодарность это наша эмоциональная
реакция выражающаяся В желании
отблагодарить за то что нам сделали или
дали Не будучи обязанными существует два
вида благодарности Первое это
благодарность к кому-то и второе
благодарность за что-то благодарность
кому-то возникает по отношению к тому
кто дал или сделал Для нас благо
благодарность за что-то же возникает за
то что нам дали Или что для нас сделали
в вопросе с пониманием того к кому
испытывать благодарность обычно не
возникает проблем Здесь всё предельно
ясно если мы видим или получаем благо мы
автоматически испытываем благодарность к
автору или к тому от кого по нашему
мнению исходит Это благо Например если
это человек то нам легко определить
источник блага А если мы не видим
источника блага то мы что то мы
испытываем благодарность ко всевышнему
или ко вселенной как говорят атеисты
проблема существует в определении того
за что люди испытывают благодарность и
как сделать так чтобы люди были
благодарны за ваши труды или результат
труда которые вы Им
дали Давайте разбираться существует
только одна причина почему дети или
другие люди не ценят то что вы им даёте
И почему они не ценят ту жизнь которую
вы для них создали по этому поводу есть
такая шутка или анекдот можно сказать
который гласит что вы всю жизнь пате
пате Работайте преодолевай препятствия
Решаете проблемы чтобы ваши дети потом
сидели у психолога И прощали вас так вот
когда Я размышлял над этой темой Я понял
что единственной причиной
неблагодарности человека является то что
он нечётко понимает кто и что ему обязан
Давать или делать И кто и что ему ничем
не обязаны для того чтобы у человека
появилось Чуст благодарности нужно чтобы
Этот человек понимал первое кто ему
обязан то есть что он обязан давать что
он обязан не давать что он не обязан
давать что он обязан делать что он
обязан не делать что он не обязан делать
второе Кто ему не обязан третье что ему
не обязаны давать четвёртое что ему не
обязаны делать то есть по сути у ребёнка
если вы это относитесь к ребёнку или
другому человеку у него должен должно
быть чёткое понимание кто что ему обязан
и кто что ему не обязаны делать или
давать или так далее после того как
человек понял кто ему обязан И что он
обязан или не обязан у него возникает
понимание того что выходит за рамки
обязанностей и это первая причина или
источник благодарности Чтобы объяснить
человеку что ему и кто ему обязан или
что вы обязаны или не обязаны ему делать
Вы можете Просто сесть с ним и
поговорить на эту тему либо второй
вариант Вы можете перестать ему давать
то что вы не обязаны или перестать
делать то что вы ему не обязаны
естественно у него возникнет вопрос
почему вдруг система сломалась И это
заставит его задать вам вопрос А
почему ты не продолжаешь это делать Вот
тогда вы можете сесть и поговорить с ним
по поводу того что вы обязаны ему делать
А что вы не обязаны вот как только
человек понял эти вещи и получил что-то
что выходит за рамки обязанностей
кого-то или кто-то сделал для него то
что не входит в рамки его обязанностей
так сразу же у человека возникает
чувство благодарности и желание
отблагодарить И это чувство возникает
автоматически Если вы благодарны за то
что я делаю обязательно Поставьте лайк
Напишите комментарии чтобы я мог
прочитать и прочувствовать вашу
благодарность Я понял что не существует
неблагодарных людей есть люди которые
нечётко понимают кто и что им что-то
должен делать или давать и кто и что им
ничем не обязаны Родители которые думают
что их дети не благодарные на самом деле
к вам обращаюсь ваши дети благодарные
просто они нечётко понимают что и
сколько вы им обязаны или должны дать
или сделать Вы можете это легко
проверить кстати посмотрите как ваши
дети общаются в ресторане Или в обществе
Они же всё время говорят там Спасибо
пожалуйста Они же благодарны по
отношению к другим людям
Это значит что просто вашим детям нужно
объяснить или показать что входит в круг
ваших обязанностей по отношению к ним А
что не входит Ну вот если я приведу свой
пример Я со своими детьми у
меня несовершеннолетние дети есть Ну им
по 15 лет я им объяснил Круг
обязанности нас как родителей первое я
сют делать для дете
второе - это научить детей
взаимодействовать с другими людьми и
третье помочь детям найти свою миссию Ну
и если говорить про материальное то про
материальное Я говорю это дать крышу над
головой одежду питание и хорошее
образование всё на этом наша
родительская забота и наши родительские
обязанности
заканчиваются се говорим и мои дети
достаточно хорошо это понимают Я думаю
что с причиной или источником
благодарности мы разобрались Давайте
теперь поговорим о степени благодарности
или о глубине благодарности исходя из
той логики которую я вам привёл Вы
можете понять что размер или глубина
благодарности напрямую зависит от
размера или ценности того блага которое
получил человек если человек не понимает
ценности тех благ которые он получил то
он их либо не будет ценить либо будет
недооценивать а почему это происходит
потому что оценить то благо которое ему
дают или делают для него можно только
если первое ребнок или человек получил
не только результат но и участвовал в
процессе То есть он может оценить благо
через то каких усилий оно стоило Поэтому
если вы хотите чтобы ваш ребёнок или
любой другой человек Оценил то что вы
ему дали или то что вы для него делаете
дайте ему возможность увидеть и оценить
Весь процесс достижения этого результата
это либо больше Рассказывайте ему про
проблемы которые вы решаете либо лучше
всего подключайте их Для решения
проблемы и дайте им возможность
попробовать заработать хоть какие-то
деньги чтобы они поняли насколько это
сложно то есть ваша задача дать ребёнку
возможность оценить тот труд который вы
для этого для них делаете ребёнок или
любой другой человек оценить результат
смогут только через понимание или
прочувствовали процесса который нужно
пройти чтобы получить такой результат
они должны потратить свою энергию время
и нести риски чтобы шкурой
прочувствовать то что вы для них делаете
когда вы создаёте достаток и богатство
вы ребёнку даёте результат но не даёте
поучаствовать в процессе из-за этого
ребёнок не ценит этот результат и ведёт
себя неблагодарным образом это не значит
что ребёнок не благодарен пою он вет
себя неблагодарным образом А почему
нетто
рудно которые вы сделали для того чтобы
обеспечить ему этот результат Разве он
виноват в этом поэтому Когда вы даёте
результат но не даёте процесс то он
вырастает неблагодарным не из-за того
что он плохой А из-за того что он не
видел результата он не знает цену он не
видел процесс вернее он не знает цену
этому результату это кстати очень
классный инструмент обязательно его
Попробуйте примените в своей жизни это
можно применить в отношении дете
и так далее Если вы хотите получать
больше инсайтов и больше инструментов
Как улучшить свою жизнь Как сделать
людей благодарными подписывайтесь на мой
Telegram канал где Я делюсь своими
инсайта и размышлениями ссылку я оставлю
внизу в описании к этому видео второй
способ это сделать так чтобы ребёнок или
любой другой человек ценил то что вы
делаете или делаете для него это лишите
его этого отнимите у него то что вы не
обязаны были ему давать или Перестаньте
делать то что вы не обязаны ему делать
мы люди и поэтому только тогда когда
ребнок или любой другой человек лишается
того что было он понимает ценность того
и будет вам благодарен Когда вы вернёте
ему это предварительно объяснив что вы
совсем не обязаны ему это делать либо
давать резюмируя скажу первое не бывает
неблагодарных людей бывают люди которые
нечётко понимают кто что им должен и кто
Что им не должен
что ему обязан А кто не обязан второе
чтобы у человека появилось чувство
благодарности у него должно быть чёткое
понимание что ему дают больше чем
обязано третье глубина благодарности
зависит от того насколько Ясно человек
понимает ценность тех благ которые ему
дают или тех благ которые для него
делают
четвёртое чтобы человек понял ценность
того что ему дают или то для чего что
для него делают он должен пройти процесс
и понять
насколько он сложен он должен
прочувствовать это пятое чтобы человек
Оценил что у него есть и то что для него
делают другие люди нужно у него это
отнять либо перестать для него это
делать а потом вернуть но объяснив что
ему это дают хотя и не обязаны И для
него это делают хотя и не обязанный
человек ценит только тогда когда он
лишается этого я надеюсь это видео
растаяло в вашей голове ВС по полочкам и
теперь вы чт понимаете благодарности и
теперь понимаете как сделать так чтобы
люди или ваш ребёнок был вам благодарен